SAN THIS ONE TONIGHT SO
FAR.
THEY'RE ON PUCKS FIRSTONNOR HELK
INDIVIDUAL MOV SKINNER.
BACK TO DUBOIS.
BUSHING OFF.
CONNOR CAN'T GET ONE THROUGH.
AND THE GRETZKY.
>>> AN UNBELEL
THE STICK.
WRAP IT.
GRADE As I WAS TALKING BY STUART
SKINNER.
GOAT IT WITH HIS RIGHT TOE AND
O
STAY DOWN ON McDAVID'S OF
THE ZONE.
THAT SETS UP THIS OER ABLE TO CL
THE REBOUND.
SHOT, HARKINS, KICK SAVE MADE BY
SKINNER.
THIS ONE AND FIRE IT THROUGH THD
NOW WST.
HYMAN'S STILL GOT IT.
DISHES OFF.
JUSTHE
POST.
REBOUND TO SCHEIFELE.
MORRISSE AND THAT
MIGHT HAVE TICKED OFF FIRST THE
GLOVE AND THEN THE POST. WITH S.
HE'S BEEN BRILLIANT TONIGHT AND
IT'S STILL
THE FIRST QUICK RELEASE BY
CONNOR FOUGHT OFF
A SHOT.
SAVE MADE WITH THE BLOCKER,
HELLEBUYCK! IT UP.
GREAT OPPORTUNITY TOP OF THEIR
UNLOCKS THE SCORELESS TIE AT
NIK EHLERS THAT GIVES HIS TEAM A
1-0 LEADCK REACTION BY EDMONTOND
GUESS WHO, PIERRE-LUC
DUBOIS.
SKINNER ON THE
HE COULDLD AND
CECI WILL PLAY SKINNER, A SPECTR
BY HELLEBUYCK!
HE DOES, AND A GLOVE SAVE MADE
BY SKINNER!EBUYCK STAYED RIGHT M
AS HE MOVED BACK TO HIS LEFT.CK!
SAVE, SKINNER! FAKES, FAKES, BA.
.
SNAPPED ONE RIGHT INT OPENER, HD
IT.
EDMONTON 2-WINNIPEG 1!